pour vivre sur la lune en abaissant de
quoi on se pose des questions quelque
peu futuriste au centre de loisirs jean
louis barrault de bois d'arcy depuis le
mois de janvier des apprentis
astronautes volontaires sont entrés en
mission lune et cette année on s'engager
à travailler sur la les collègues
donc ça passe très bien au niveau des
enfants en plus il travaille sur table
elle donc c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que sur papier très équipes
se sont formées dans quatre communes de
saint quentin en yvelines
piloté par l'association ingenious en
collaboration avec les différents
centres de loisirs elles sont inscrites
à la first lego league du niort des kits
leur sont fournis pour construire base
lunaire et robot adapté c'est vous c'est
vous les ingénieurs à moi je pose des
questions c'est tôt sur un contre
bienveillance ou les enfants ils vont
préparer un thème le thème cette année
c'est le 50e anniversaire du premier pas
de l'homme sur la lune et 20 sont cela
ils vont créer une base lunaire et ils
vont réfléchir à comment vivre sur la
lune comme ça ils vont apprendre d
des termes techniques mais aussi vont
apprendre à s'exprimer en public parce
qu'il faut qu'ils défendent leurs idées
sortent du crabe les enfants de 6 à 9
ans réfléchissent et expérimentent comme
de vrais programmateurs ou architectes
et je faisais avancer la voiture pour
pour transporter des modèles
d'approvisionnement jusqu'à la base
unique en train de faire une espèce de
base et moitié base moitié sas et le
tout pour être prêt pour la rencontre en
finale le samedi 13 avril et j'ai pas
envie que ça cesse carling
il tenait à vous y voir les autres
équipes s'il ya des copains ne reste
plus qu'à s'assurer que tout est bien
sécurisée pour pouvoir s'envoler et
vivre sur la lune